Given that their main and really only purposes
is violently exploding, you might be surprised
to learn that most explosives utilised by
the military are shockingly stable.
So much so, in fact, that, contrary to what
is often depicted in movies and video games,
plastic explosives like C-4 won’t explode
if you shoot them or set them on fire.
In fact, C-4 won’t even explode if you shoot
it while it is currently on fire.
Indeed, beyond the benefit of being able to
shape the explosive in a variety of ways to
accomplish a given destructive goal, one of
the main reasons plastic explosives like C-4
are utilised so extensively by the military
is precisely because they are largely inert
and can be handled without specialised equipment.
Further, creating C-4 is noted as being a
relatively simple process that involves mixing
a plasticizer with a conventional explosive
(in this case usually cyclotrimethylene-trinitramine,
often referred to as “RDX” or “Royal
Demolition Explosive”- or for the non-Brits
“Research Department Explosive”).
While exact ratios vary somewhat, for reference
in its C-4 the U.S. military currently uses
a mixture of 91% RDX, 5.3% of the plasticizer
dioctyl sebacate, 2.1% of the synthetic rubber
Polyisobutylene, and 1.6% mineral oil or,
for civilian use, motor oil, giving such C4
its telltale odor of, well, motor oil.
Commonly likened to ordinary modelling clay
in texture and consistency, C-4 and most other
plastic explosives can be shaped, stored and
molded just as easily.
The key difference being that, unlike modelling
clay, a mere half kilogram of C-4 can turn
a typical vehicle into a pile of scrap metal.
The key to making this happen, though, is
attaching some form of blasting cap.
As the name suggests, these blasting caps
rely on a smaller, controlled explosion which
will in turn cause the explosive components
within the C-4 to go off, resulting in the
C-4 producing a wave of gasses, including
nitrogen and carbon oxides, that rapidly expand
out at upwards of 18,000 mph.
So fast is this effect that it actually creates
something of a temporary vacuum around the
core blast area.
This results in a second, much less violent,
wave of air collapsing in on the vacuum after
the initial blast.
Not keen to just rely on theory, the US Army
has conducted countless sensitivity tests
on C-4 and other plastic explosive compounds,
shooting them with bullets of varying calibres
and even putting them within feet of things
like hand grenades to see if that explosion
or subsequent shrapnel could set the C-4 off.
The Army has even conducted tests to see if
things like fire will cause C-4 to explode,
all with little effect.
In fact, it turns out C-4 not only remains
stable while on fire but it actually burns
quite slowly, making it a good fire starter
if you don’t mind the poisonous fumes.
While you might think soldiers would be scared
to use this compound in this way, both because
of perhaps worrying about an accidental explosion
or from the noxious gasses given off, amazingly,
during the Vietnam war using small chunks
of C-4 as tinder to light campfires, or even
as the sole source of the fire itself, was
indeed a thing many soldiers did, despite
military brass advising against it owing to
the poisonous gasses given off.
Further, beyond its use as an explosive, fire
starter, and badass modeling clay, it turns
out that when eaten in extremely small amounts,
C-4 is known to produce a mild high likened
to being drunk, something soldiers in Vietnam
also took advantage of.
It’s probably worth mentioning at this point
that when consumed in anything other than
extremely tiny quantities, C-4 can cause a
host of health problems, as noted in a case
study published in the Journal of the Royal
Society of Medicine in 2002 where a soldier
decided to swallow about a cubic centimeter
of the substance…
Potential resulting complications of mimicking
this moronic act include “generalized seizures,
lethargy, coma, muscular twitching, hyperreflexia,
myalgias, headaches, vomiting, mild renal
injury and haematuria (blood in your pee)”
Back to the extreme stability of C-4- as they
often do, the show Mythbusters took the idea
of testing this to its logical extreme, shooting
a piece that was currently on fire with a
high-explosive incendiary round.
The C-4 stubbornly refused to explode even
then, despite the incendiary round giving
a nice little blast on impact.
There is one caveat to all this, however.
It turns out there is a way to set off C-4
by shooting at it.
How?
While there are a variety of designs for blasting
caps, some may be set off via being hit with
a bullet, thus providing the needed energy
to cause the C-4 itself to explode.
Why this is an extremely unlikely scenario
in the real world is because these blasting
caps are typically very small (think a half
used pencil) and anyone trying to shoot at
them would presumably want to be a fair distance
away just in case they were successful.
This all becomes an even less likely in real
world scenarios given that you don’t put
the blast cap in the C-4 until you yourself
are preparing to actually make it go boom.
So, in the end, while there are certainly
many unstable explosives that will happily
release their destructive power if you were
to shoot them, it turns out plastic explosives
and pretty much the majority of explosives
used by militaries and for industrial use
the world over are almost always shockingly
stable precisely because these organizations
aren’t keen on deploying explosive devices
that might go off unexpectedly.
Speaking of shooting at explosive devices,
during WWI there are documented instances
of soldiers using shotguns to destroy thrown
hand grenades before they could reach their
target.
For example, in Leroy Thompson’s U.S. Combat
Shotguns book, he notes the following account
where a group of soldiers acted in concert
in this way: “Their first warnings were
German ‘potato masher’ hand grenades lobbing
through the air.
Few landed as most of them were exploded in
the air by the experts in the outposts.
Upon the failure of the grenade attack, the
enemy launched a mortar attack.
Again the trapshooters proved their worth,
deflecting the slowly arching bombs.
Finally, a vast grey wave
of the Kaiser’s best surged forward.”